bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisodes 239 ce
soir on va s'intéresser au programme
petite ville de demain
en politique
nous avons reçu les maires de 5 communes
et Sonia sélectionnées par l'État pour
faire partie du programme petite ville
de demain un programme lancé en 2020 par
le gouvernement qui vise à renforcer les
moyens des élus des villes de moins de
20.000 habitants qui exercent des
fonctions de centralité pour que ces
mères puissent développer leur projet de
territoire jusqu'à 2026 alors tout au
long de ce programme l'État va investir
3 milliards d'euros pour plus de 1600
communes parmi ces communes on retrouve
en Jarville Ballancourt-sur-Essonne
Breuillet Milly-la-Forêt ou encore la
ville de Dourdan on commence d'ailleurs
cette émission avec son maire Paolo de
Carvalho pour l'État dedans et était une
ville qui était en décrochage mais avant
de parler de cela moi j'aimerais dire
que dourdon d'abord c'est un art de
vivre à la dourdanaise c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de dire pendant ma campagne
électorale et maintenant que je suis
maire on le met d'ailleurs c'est devenu
notre slogan l'art du village
d'ourdanaise pourquoi parce que en fait
est une ville extraordinaire
extraordinaire pourquoi parce que elle a
d'abord des services publics services
publics comme un lycée trois collèges un
cinéma une piscine une médiathèque un
conservatoire des gymnase de gare RER
une gare routière en fait un hôpital
donc c'est une ville particulièrement
bien dotée en service public pour une
ville de 11000 habitants c'est assez
incroyable en France et c'est la raison
pour laquelle aussi je pense que dourdon
avait besoin de ce petit coup de pouce
qui est petite ville de demain alors une
convention d'adhésion a été signée entre
l'État et la ville de Dourdan en mai
2021 elle porte sur quatre volets
principaux et donne donc les premières
pistes de réflexion pour repenser
comment sera Dourdan dans quelques
années le Dourdan de demain alors le
premier volet traite des mobilités dans
les petites villes la voiture et le mode
de déplacement
privilégié vous souhaitez donc
développer les pistes cyclables dans la
ville mais aussi en reliant Dourdan aux
autres villages voisins dans la campagne
aussi dans la ruralité il faudra aussi
réduire le l'utilisation de la voiture
ouais alors pourquoi parce que Dourdan
c'est une ville centre d'abord c'est le
berceau décapécien c'est la capitale du
York c'est historique c'est comme ça et
on s'aperçoit effectivement que en fait
il y a deux manières de voir les choses
soit on dit les piétons contre les vélos
soit on dit les vélos contre les contre
les voitures mais en vérité dans une
ville comme celle de Dourdan on a besoin
de toutes les mobilités on a besoin de
la voiture parfois pour aller travailler
mais on a aussi besoin de se déplacer
entre les villages entre les maisons et
notamment les les collèges ou les
services publics ce qui est un peu un
peu spécial à dourdon c'est que vous
avez la ville qui est entourée d'un
périphérique et autour de ce
périphérique et bien il y a 9000
véhicules jours la question qu'on s'est
tout de suite posée c'est que est-ce que
avec 9000 véhicules jour on peut y
mettre des vélos donc on s'est dit ben
non il faut d'abord sécuriser et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on a une grande
ambition de de pouvoir mettre autour
donc de ce projet mobilité douce le vélo
au premier plan d'ailleurs la première
chose que l'on a faite à partir de
maintenant toutes les constructions qui
vont être faites sur Dourdan quand vous
allez construire un immeuble et bien
nous avons convaincu tous les
partenaires qui sont des partenaires des
constructeurs des promoteurs de pouvoir
vendre avec l'appartement le vélo ce qui
permettra demain d'avoir si on a 400
appartements 400 vélos il y a aussi une
réflexion sur la place donc de la
voiture dans le centre-ville précisément
refonte du stationnement développement
donc des recharges pour les voitures
électriques c'est le grand projet de
l'Union européenne d'arrêter la vente
des voitures thermiques il va falloir
s'y préparer qu'est-ce qui ressort de
toute cette réflexion sur le
centre-ville vous savez la meilleure des
énergies c'est celle qu'on ne consomme
pas donc moi je pense que d'abord il
faut promouvoir donc comme je vous le
disais le vélo il faut promouvoir aussi
la piétonnisation il faut savoir que
Dourdan est vraiment très très bien
adapté parce que vous avez pas mal de
rue piétonnes à Dourdan et donc
à Dourdan exactement le président
François du rover elle a bien compris et
d'ailleurs il le dit tout a démarré à
Dourdan le troisième volet c'est
l'habitat la ville a fait appel à deux
écoles d'architecture pour travailler
sur des cas concrets les étudiants de
l'école de l'ENSA Val de Seine on
travaille donc sur l'aménagement du
centre-ville et ceux de l'école Paris
Malaquais sur la valorisation de la
place du chariot alors c'est intéressant
pour la ville d'avoir un autre point de
vue un point de vue déjà jeune et puis
extérieur vous savez Corentin ce qui est
très dangereux quand vous faites de la
politique c'est les a priori et les a
priori vous savez ce qui est plus
dangereux qu'un a priori deux a priori
donc quand vous faites de la politique
faut pas avoir d'a priori et quoi de
mieux qu'un œil neuf pour effectivement
trouver des idées vous savez vous vous
êtes jeune mais quand j'ai démarré cette
aventure avec avec l'école malaquée et
l'école Paris-Val de Seine j'ai expliqué
à ces jeunes architectes que tout était
possible rien n'est obligatoire et que
l'idée c'était de se dire ayez de ne pas
un rêve mais deux ou trois rêves
d'avance devenez visionnaires et c'est
exactement ce qu'ils ont fait et moi je
suis ravi parce que ils nous ont donné
vraiment une nouvelle impulsion et
peut-être ils nous ont permis de
se dire que quelque part on avait on
s'était interdit des choses parce qu'on
avait effectivement ce dogme d'a priori
donc l'idée de d'avoir fait d'avoir fait
travailler ces jeunes artistiques que je
remercie d'ailleurs vraiment nous a
permis d'avoir une ouverture d'esprit
beaucoup plus importante parmi les
villes sélectionnées on retrouve aussi
en Jarville tout au sud de l'île de
France et parmi les projets évoqués la
refonte du centre-ville et les
transports on écoute Joan mittelhauser
et elle est située à la frontière de
l'Île-de-France au sud du département de
l'Essonne à équidistance quand on enlève
les embouteillages de Paris de Chartres
et d'Orléans et donc en Gerville a su
conserver sa propre aire d'attractivité
notamment sur le Nord Loiret
Eure-et-Loir ce qui lui permet
aujourd'hui d'avoir un centre-ville qui
est dynamique qui est attractif dans
lequel la vacance commerciale est quas
nul et c'est je dirais tant mieux et le
dispositif peut-il vivre demain va
concourir justement à continuer de
conforter aujourd'hui le rôle de
centralité secondaire parce
qu'effectivement nous n'avons pas la
même attractivité qui est temple pour
autant sur un territoire il y a ce qu'on
appelle les pôles d'équilibre et en
Jarvis le fait partie de ces pôles
d'équilibre ce pourquoi elle a été
reconnue dans le programme petit l'île
de main et donc ce pourquoi nous
souhaitons nous impliquer à travers ce
programme pour maintenir ce rôle de
centralité alors pour ce programme vous
aviez 18 mois pour établir une stratégie
on arrive bientôt à l'échéance donc de
ces 18 mois cela va permettre à votre
commune de développer donc des fonctions
de centrale de centralité de penser la
commune de demain vous souhaitez donc
réaménager le centre-ville qui est
actuellement composé de deux centres
villes alors concrètement on parle de
quoi de donner de la place aux mobilité
douce de rebancer le système de
stationnement et de dynamiser les
commerces c'est un peu ça l'idée alors
concrètement on parle de tout c'est à
dire que on parle de comment on adapte
on réinterroge un centre-ville qui dans
sa volumétrie est issue finalement de du
Moyen-Âge nos deux places nos deux
centres villes aujourd'hui
concourent à articulations de la commune
depuis en tout cas dans l'état actuel
depuis la Révolution française sauf que
le centre-ville c'est plutôt aménagé au
gré des opportunités des besoins sans
qu'on ait eu l'occasion un jour de
prendre un peu de hauteur et un peu de
recul ce que peut-il vivre de main nous
permet aujourd'hui pour vos questionner
à la fois les questions de mobilité vous
l'avez dit les questions de mobilité dit
de stationnement et de partage entre les
piétons les cycles les automobilistes de
réinterroger aussi la place de la nature
en cœur de ville on sait que ces
dernières années on a eu tendance
justement à artificialiser à bétonner
disons-le très clairement comment on
concourt à permettre aussi de renaturer
nos espaces pour les rendre plus
qualitatifs comment on redonne sa place
aussi à des lieux de rencontre de
socialisation qui permettent aussi à des
marchés d'ailleurs de pouvoir mieux
exister mieux accueillir les habitants
et comment également et bien on permet
au commerce de demeurer dynamique
attractif donc c'est à dire qu'il ne
faut pas faut bien penser la question de
l'accessibilité des commerces notamment
en termes de stationnement tout en
travaillant aussi sur faire revenir des
habitants en coeur de ville et j'en
terminerai par là le centre-ville
d'enjeu n'a pas éc presque beaucoup de
coeurs de ville ont connu jadis les
commerçants habitaient au-dessus de leur
commerce et y accéder via le commerce
sauf que avec le temps les habitudes ont
changé les commerçants ne vivent plus
dans leur boutique et en revanche les
logements qu'ils occupaient jadis
n'étant pas accessible autrement que par
le passage de la boutique et bien ce
sont vidés sont des peuplés à Angerville
on estime aujourd'hui qu'il y a entre
180 et 200 logements de coeur de ville
qui sont inhabitées c'est autant de
possibilités de reconquête et de travail
à mettre en oeuvre à travers petit livre
de main donc voilà le travail du
centre-ville ce sont tous ces éléments
qu'il va falloir justement coordonner
qu'il va falloir réfléchir concerter
parce que ce qui est important aussi
c'est la concertation à la fois la
concertation avec le monde des
commerçants avec les habitants du cœur
de ville et plus globalement les
habitants de la commune pour qu'ils
s'approprient et qu'on soit pas dans ce
qui a pu se voir parfois sur d'autres
communes des grands travaux pharaoniques
qui n'ont de sens que de se faire
plaisir mais bien des travaux qui
correspondent aux attentes qui sont
partagées et qui se permettent de dire
que en Javier ce projet sur le 21e
siècle totalement qui est déjà bien
entré mais totalement et adapte son
centre-ville aux nouveaux usages
repenser la ville de demain c'est aussi
repenser les transports de demain aussi
quand on habite à Angerville la voiture
est quasiment indispensable aujourd'hui
alors on parle beaucoup de réduire donc
l'usage de l'automobile dans les grandes
villes dans les grandes couronnes est-ce
que quels sont les pistes de réflexion
que vous avez vous pour le Angerville de
demain est-ce que le Angerville de
demain sera un Angerville avec beaucoup
de monde voiture alors il faut
distinguer deux choses il faut
distinguer les habitants d'Angerville et
la question du du transport pour ceci et
également les personnes qui viennent de
l'extérieur consommer sur la commune et
donc je commencerai à part cela ça
retour à ce que je disais par rapport à
l'aire d'attractivité de la commune vous
avez
à peu près une vingtaine de kilomètres
au sud d'Angerville une myriade de petit
village qui compte moins de 100 150
habitants avec aucun commerce ces
personnes là ne peuvent opérer leur
démarche du quotidien sans véhicule et
il les opère depuis la commune d'ange à
destination de la commune d'Angerville
ils vont voir leur médecin ils vont dans
les commerces de centre-ville dans les
grandes surfaces et autres c'est ce qui
permet engager les dynamiques donc on
sait que à brève échéance à tout le
moins toutes ces petits villages là ne
vont pas être maillés par des réseaux de
bus par de transport Ferrer et que par
conséquent la place de l'automobile va
rester prégnante maintenant on doit
repenser aussi l'usage du véhicule la
place du véhicule à nous de mieux
distinguer les stationnements qui sont à
proximité du cœur de ville de mieux
réfléchir pour mieux orienter justement
ce flux là et puis sur la question des
habitants
c'est continuer à œuvrer en faveur à la
fois de liaison ferrées qui existent
aujourd'hui avec le train express
régional Paris Centre Val de Loire alors
qui est une ligne donc c'est la ligne
Paris-Orléans qui est déjà très
structurée sur laquelle il est compliqué
aujourd'hui d'obtenir des arrêts de TER
supplémentaires on a très peu on en a 7
par jour ce qui est loin de satisfaire
la demande tel qu'on pourrait
l'avoir en Île-de-France et c'est tout
le travail partenarial qui est entrepris
en lien avec l'Île-de-France mobilité
pour en corollaire mettre en oeuvre des
transports en bus et aussi adapter le
cadencement de ces bus aux réalités aux
usages traduction si la seule
possibilité qu'on offre à nos
concitoyens sont des bus qui mettent 40
à 45 minutes pour rallier la gare RER la
plus proche qui est celle des tempes
c'est absolument pas compétitif et vous
ne laisserez pas renoncer à la voiture
individuelle peut-être au mieux
irez-vous les encourager à abandonner
l'auto-solisme et aller sur du
covoiturage mais pour autant on sait
qu'on a des moyens beaucoup plus
efficaces pour réduire l'usage de la
voiture à condition qu'en face les
moyens de transport soit adaptés et de
sur ce sujet qu'on a déjà bien avancé
qui le fausse possibilité avec la mise
en œuvre d'ailleurs de liaison directe
ce qu'on appelle le 1 sur 3 en heure de
pointe une liaison sur trois et direct
entre en Jarville et étampes ce qui rend
aujourd'hui plus compétitif de prendre
le bus que de prendre votre voiture
individuelle si vous comptez le temps de
trouver une place de stationnement de
vous garer de rejoindre la gare alors
que le bus vous emmène d'un point B
c'est à dire le point B c'est votre
train directement et sans sans
difficulté à Breuillet au centre de
l'Essonne on prépare la construction
d'un nouvel écoquartier dont les travaux
vont débuter cette année on écoute
Véronique Mayer maire de la ville alors
il commence cette année et je précise
tout de même que petite ville de demain
c'est pas ce qui a permis de mettre en
place ce projet ça c'est un projet qui
se travaille ce nouveau éco-quartier ça
se travaille depuis plus de 15 ans déjà
puisque il y a il y a cette friche
industrielle quand on en 2020
l'état flèche et nomme broyée quand il
lance de réinvestir les friches
industrielles évidemment on va commencer
nous à lancer certaines études et ce qui
nous aide c'est le dispositif petite
ville de demain qui nous a permis de
recruter une chef de projet qui est
arrivé dans la ville en janvier 2022
donc ça fait un peu plus d'un an
maintenant qu'elle est avec nous et
c'est indispensable parce que c'est un
travail à plein temps pour pouvoir
mobiliser tous les outils dans le cadre
de petites villes de demain qui sont mis
à notre disposition que ce soit pour
travailler sur l'immobilité travailler
sur l'habitat travailler sur la
renaturation du pont des gains et
également de notre centre-ville alors il
y a effectivement un diagnostic qui a
été mené ce diagnostic il a été présenté
en décembre 2022 voté à notre conseil
municipal de décembre également puisque
deux fois dans l'année on rencontre au
niveau des services de l'État c'est
normal on nous donne des subventions ça
nous donne des outils donc on doit
rendre compte de notre travail et nous
l'avons fait au mois de décembre et donc
on a déterminé huit piliers parmi ces 8
piliers il y a effectivement un volet
habitat important sur le pont des gains
et une réhabilitation aussi de l'habitat
du vieil habitat en centre-ville ce
nouveau quartier va représenter environ
450 logements dont 30% donc de logements
sociaux Breuillet d'une ville donc je
l'ai dit au début de cette émission de
d'environ 8800 habitants ça va
représenter une augmentation importante
de la population pour la la commune va
falloir anticiper pour s'adapter en
termes d'adaptation des services publics
en termes de circulation aussi tout à
fait alors gouverner scientificité sinon
gouverne pas on ne dirige pas on prend
pas de décision il faut se porter plus
loin et donc les décisions que l'on
prend aujourd'hui sont des décisions que
l'on prend en voyant les conséquences à
2030 2035 même et effectivement alors le
chiffre de 450 logements c'est un
chiffre qui est établi depuis 2013
dans le précédent plan local de
l'urbanisme l'espace était déjà fléché
et là on est on y arrive donc c'est 450
logements environ 450 logements 30% de
logements sociaux pour pouvoir répondre
à nos objectifs d'arriver à 25% de
logements locatifs sociaux sur la
commune donc depuis plusieurs années
dans tous les programmes on met
automatiquement 30% pour pouvoir arriver
finalement en moyenne à ce 25%. et la
principale conséquence d'une
augmentation de la population ou d'un
rejeunissement de la population parce
qu'on le voit déjà depuis quelques
années à broyer c'est l'ouverture de
classe donc là on estime que d'ici 2030
le l'augmentation l'évolution des
effectifs scolaires
nécessitent la construction de cette
nouvelle classe donc on y réfléchit
activement et on fait plus qui réfléchir
on a déjà lancé une étude sur ce sujet
et en termes de situation aussi alors en
termes de circulation
je vais avant tout parler non pas de la
circulation voiture mais de la
circulation piétonne et vélo les
circulations douces trottinette
également puisque la volonté c'est de
penser ce nouveau quartier et de penser
la réhabilitation de notre centre-ville
avec des circulations apaisées ce qui
aujourd'hui est tout de même très
compliqué puisque nous avons des
beaucoup de véhicules par jour qui passe
on a à l'heure actuelle le cerema qui
est en train de faire d'une réaliser une
étude complète sur le diagnostic de la
circulation aujourd'hui et ensuite on
nous proposera des solutions à midi
Laforêt ville de 4500 habitants on
compte sur petite ville de demain pour
développer encore davantage
l'attractivité touristique de la ville
connue notamment pour sa halle on écoute
Bernard boulet ancien député et
conseiller municipal de Milly-la-Forêt
en du programme petite ville de demain
il est accompagné du maire de la ville
Patrice Sainsard oui alors la
restauration de la halle était amorcée
avant le programme PVD le PVD est venu
en apport derrière à compléter
finalement nous avons nous avons
d'autres monuments qui étaient prévus de
restaurer dans le temps et moyens
financiers d'une petite ville sont étant
limitées PVD et amène quand même une
même financière de plus de 8 millions
d'euros 8 millions et demi d'euros
exactement dont 60% et subventionné par
le programme donc ça nous a permis de
mettre en priorité un certain nombre de
restaurations qu'on n'aurait pas pu
faire
sinon en particulier donc la fin de la
halle le colombier la chapelle
Saint-Blaise qui est refaite
complètement et exceptionnellement la
chapelle la chapelle Saint-Blaise le
coûtera rien à la commune puisque nous
sommes nous sommes subventionnés à 100%
il y a eu la Fondation du patrimoine qui
a abondé et le préfet monsieur Jallon
l'ancien préfet avait donner une
dérogation pour qu'on puisse financer à
100% ce qui n'est pas toloré en principe
les plafonds étant de de 80%. alors vous
souhaitez dans ce projet aussi créer
prochainement une maison des arts et de
l'artisanat alors à quoi est-ce que
cette maison va-t-elle servir alors on a
sur le secteur de la Communauté de
Communes une via artisanale très forte
en artisans d'art il y a à peu près 70
artisans d'art sur le sur le secteur et
depuis longtemps ces gens-là vous
souhaitaient se réunir dans dans quelque
part pour avoir une vitrine pour
présenter leurs différentes
œuvres on a vu que dans le programme
petite ville de demain on avait la
possibilité de réaliser quelque chose en
plus Milly à la volonté de d'avoir le
label Ville et Métiers d'Art donc on a
trouvé un local qui appartient à la
mairie qui est à rénové partiellement et
qui plaît aux artisans on a monté le
projet avec eux on en est aujourd'hui
quasiment le cahier des charges pour
consulter l'architecte et on est
subventionné là aussi à hauteur de 70 70
% ce sera une vitrine pour les artisans
certains d'entre eux travailleront
d'ailleurs dans les locaux ce qui
permettra de faire passer les scolaires
et communiquer sur le travail qui font
et pourquoi pas faire de la formation
également
renforcer l'offre des services aux
habitants c'est aussi une des
problématiques de la plupart des des
communes de grandes couronnes en zone
rurale alors vous souhaitez vous
développer davantage le réseau de
vidéoprotection sur la commune et aussi
de créer une maison de santé
disciplinaire pour faire venir des
professionnels de santé on le sait toute
la quasiment toute l'Île-de-France et en
zone est une zone qui manque de
professionnels de santé de médecins et
énormément de concurrence pour les
attirer alors du coup cette maison de
santé à vocation à rendre disons midi
plus attractif pour les personnels de
santé
à mettre une vidéo protection en place
et disons vu le coup que ça coûte pour
des communes comme la nôtre disons qu'on
ne peut pas tout faire en même temps
donc c'est vrai donc on va pouvoir
bénéficier des de subventions
supplémentaires pour continuer à couvrir
l'ensemble de la commune et donc c'est
vrai que ça nous permet de diminuer d'un
certain nombre de
de méfaits qui sont effectués au sein de
la ville et puis voilà donc c'est et on
sécurise un petit peu les gens sont plus
tranquilles à partir du moment où on est
il y a de la vidéo protection
donc pour la maison de santé on va le
faire à deux mais voilà c'est vrai que
on a le même problème comme dans
beaucoup de communes rurales et pour
compléter un petit peu je vais vous
donner de dire disons qu'on est
maintenant en zone rouge malheureusement
on a eu la chance à une certaine période
c'est que tous nos médecins se sont
installés en même temps et ils partent à
la retraite tous en même temps donc
étaler sur quelques années de différence
mais voilà c'est ça et donc on ne pensez
pas que on aurait cette pénurie de
médecin généraliste et qui maintenant
l'ensemble de on peut dire de la France
donc c'est vrai que même si on est
proche de la région parisienne on n'a
pas plus de gens qui veulent venir
s'installer chez nous que qu'ailleurs à
Ballancourt enfin le programme petite
ville de demain sera l'occasion de
rénover énergétiquement la commune et
les bâtiments de la municipalité sera
l'occasion aussi d'avancer le projet de
maison de santé on le sait une grande
partie de l'île de France est en zone
priorité on écoute le maire de
Balancourt Jacques myone le plus
énergivore c'est le Cosec il y en a deux
salles
polyvalentes plus des salles
spécialisées en dojo salle de gym salle
de tennis de table voilà on a donc la
cellule qui est effectivement qui va
être la priorité donc on
dès l'année prochaine on va s'attaquer à
travailler ça quitte a aussi à
travailler sur la pose de panneaux
solaires puisque c'est vrai que tant
qu'à faire aussi essayer de de
rentabiliser un peu ce tout ce travail
donc c'est c'est priorité après après ce
sont les écoles puisqu'on a des écoles
anciennes notamment une école qui a plus
de 100 ans donc mais bon on a ça c'est
des vieilles Molières ça ça tient mais
il faut peut-être trouver une isolation
approprié enfin quatrième projet celui
de la création d'une maison médicale
Ballancourt est en zone d'intervention
prioritaire comme une grande partie de
l'Essonne d'ailleurs selon l'agence
régionale de santé alors aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment des défis pour toutes les
communes d'attirer de nouveaux médecins
mais finalement toutes les communes
veulent attirer des nouveaux médecins
donc comment comment faire pour tirer
son épingle du jeu si j'ai envie de dire
dans cette histoire c'est vrai alors
déjà comment faire
d'essayer de leur offrir un local de
qualité mais c'est vrai que on en
discute beaucoup avec les collègues dans
cette désertification médicale on en est
à un peu à faire la concurrence les uns
des autres alors je sais qu'il y a même
des communes qui payent qui donnent des
certaines sommes pour pouvoir accueillir
les médecins nous d'une part on n'a pas
les moyens d'autre part c'est pas notre
philosophie il faut dire soit ils
viennent soit bon s'il préfère aller
prendre de l'argent ailleurs ils vont
prendre de l'argent ailleurs donc on
essaie de travailler avec cette maison
médicale donc on a déjà réussi à
récupérer un médecin généraliste et un
cardiologue en espérant en récupérer
davantage mais si je peux dire un petit
mot c'est que on a notre maison médicale
pour l'instant il est partagée en deux
puisque on a loué une partie du
locaux à la gendarmerie puisqu'on est en
train de refaire la Casa de gendarmerie
qui appartient en Amérique Ballancourt
on est en train de le refaire donc on
les allait ménager pendant 6 mois ils
occupent une aile donc pour l'instant on
peut pas l'occuper pour de futurs
médecins mais dès qu'ils seront partis
on va faire on va partir à la chasse
c'est le cas de dire au médecin et en
espérant que ce qu'on leur propose au
niveau qualité de travail et puis on va
dire soutien de la mairie suffira on
verra bien rapidement quels sont les
professionnels que que qui vous
intéressent aujourd'hui
surtout un médecin général parce qu'on a
lié à la nouvelle population nouvelle
population
qui n'a pas de médecin parce que les
médecins actuels ils gardent leur
patients et ils ouvrent pas à de
nouveaux patients donc c'est un vrai
problème merci beaucoup c'est la fin de
l'hebdo-politique merci de nous avoir
suivis à bientôt pour un nouveau numéro
et en attendant très bonne soirée à tous
sur Radio sensation
[Musique]